Alhamdulillah.
Why should
[Silence]
tonight I want to share a narration of
our prophet.
It's actually two narrations
and tomorrow night inshallah we will
continue and pick up where we left off
in.
These narrations were collected by
Muslim
on the authority
of
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
warns us in these narrations and
enlightens us.
It's important for us to understand
something
and that is that whatever Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala chose to speak about
in the Quran
as far as the
ailments of the heart and the issues in
the prophet's time
was in them and he spoke about it in the
Quran
that is to secure
and make sure that all Muslims
afterwards will have access to that.
This means that it's something that is
not going to go away. It's always going
to be a part of
humanity, a part of our environment,
a part of our social environment that
we have to navigate.
And one of those things is hypocrisy.
and be felt.
Hypocrisy is incredibly terrifying.
And that is because
hypocrisy is not just yes or no. It's
not just black or white as they say.
It's a spectrum. Right? We hear this
often. It's a spectrum. Ne is a
spectrum.
When we look at the essence of
hypocrisy, what is the essence of
hypocrisy?
The essence of hypocrisy
is that what is inside doesn't match
what is outside. That's the essence of
hypocrisy.
If we were to say boil down the attitude
of hypocrisy,
what is the attitude of hypocrisy?
The attitude of hypocrisy is
what can I get
and what can I not give. This is the
attitude of hypocrisy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
the
essence of hypocrisy.
They say with their tongues, what is not
in their hearts
what is outside doesn't match what is
what is inside.
And the attitude which is what can I
gain when it's for me I'm here and when
it's asked of me I refrain.
[Silence]
The attitude of I am with the Muslims
when there's something to celebrate or
something to gain.
But I am not with the Muslims when it is
something that I have to sacrifice or
something that I have to give. Again,
this is a spectrum.
This is a spectrum. And because it's a
spectrum, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
refers in the Quran to the hypocrites.
will be immoral.
And those who have an illness in their
hearts, they're not fully fully fully
hypocrites. They're not disbelievers.
They believe, but they have elements of
hypocrisy in them.
And for this reason, hypocrisy is so
terrifying
because the place of hypocrisy is the
lowest level of the hellfire.
Allah Subhanahua says that the
hypocrites are in the lowest levels of
hell and even you could not find a
victor or a relief for them. Speaking to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And so hypocrisy
is a spectrum in the sense that a person
can have elements of hypocrisy and these
parts of himself where do they belong in
the lowest parts of hell.
This is why it is so frightening. A
person can have these elements in
himself in herself and they are carrying
around within their body and within
their souls and hearts things that
belong in the lowest levels of hell.
And so for this reason, Allah
mainly in the Quran and especially
during the Medani era after Hijra
focused on the hypocrites the most and
exposing them, mentioning their
characteristics, their aspects, etc. If
we were to look at this attitude, the
attitude of when the Muslims have
something to gain, I'm a Muslim.
And when it's time to give of yourself,
, this is none of my business.
How common place is this attitude?
for instance, how do we apply this
to our lives? A person may come to the
masid
and mistreat the masid
and interrupt and disrupt
and then say the masid belongs to Allah
now it belongs to Allah and they're part
of the masid now right but when it comes
time to come let's clean the masid let's
give our money to the masid let's
volunteer our time to the masid nowhere
to be out. These kinds of small things
that you notice, this is what eats away
at the Muslim well-being and the Muslim
body. The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said that the Muslim are one body
one body.
If one part of the body is ailing, the
rest of the body suffers with
sleeplessness and fever because of that
one ailing part. Correct? Here's the
problem with hypocrisy. Hypocrisy is the
cancer of the Muslim ummah
just physical cancer is to the
human body.
Why is that? What is cancer? What is it?
Cancer
are cells
that trick your body into thinking that
they are part of you and your body
starts to build blood vessels for the
cancer and sends oxygen to the cancer
and sends nourishment to the cancer even
though this cancer is what's killing
you.
And so the cancer takes all it can from
the body and gives nothing back in
return. And this is what makes the body
fall. This is what spells the demise of
the body. And hypocrisy
does the same thing. It is hypocrisy is
the cancer of the Muslim ummah's body
just cancer is to the to the human
physical body.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasallam said
[Silence]
he said
four traits.
Whoever has these four traits is a
fullblown hypocrite mon.
And whoever has of these traits then
this person has elements of hypocrisy in
him until he abandons these traits. In
another narration in Sah Muslim he said
he said that the sign of a hypocrite are
three things
and when he mentioned them he said
he said he is a fullblown hypocrite even
if he prays prays and fasts and claims
to be a Muslim. Now, it doesn't mean
that whoever has these elements, even if
they have all of them, that this person
is hopeless and their soul is damned and
they are no longer Muslim. That is not
what the narration means. What this
means is this person has given himself
over to hypocrisy.
Why? Because hypocrisy is viewed as
being a separate rank from the ranks of
the believers.
It is a separate rank. They are not.
And so when a person has all of these
traits, they have stood in their ranks
even if only with their actions.
And so what are these traits? He said,
"When he speaks, lies come out. When he
speaks, he lies."
Now, notice the wording here. When he
speaks, he lies. When he speaks, this
doesn't mean that this person says one
or two lies here and there, a mistruth,
an exaggeration. And this is something
that is very hard to find someone who's
completely purged of that, especially
with the way people speak and so forth.
We all suffer from a little bit of
hyperbole. We all suffer from a little
bit of exaggeration and embellishment.
We all suffer from selective truth,
things that we say and hide other
things. This is something that happens
on occasion.
However, a person who, notice the
wording,
[Arabic recitation]
slight lies here and there, mistruths,
exaggerations. No, no, no. He said when
he speaks, he lies. Meaning this is his
nature.
His nature is just lies flow naturally.
This is a sign of hypocrisy. a major
sign of hypocrisy.
The next he says,
notice the wording, and when he
promises, he breaks his promise. We've
all been forced to break our promise at
one point or another. Correct? Every one
of us. But there's a difference between
that and intending to break your promise
when you're making the promise. This is
hypocrisy.
When he promises, he breaks his promise.
Meaning the moment he makes the promise,
he has no intention of fulfilling that
promise.
Another he says,
"And if he is entrusted,
he is treacherous."
If he is entrusted, he is treacherous.
That's the nature of hypocrisy. Remember
we mentioned in the introduction to this
that what is the essence of hypocrisy?
The outside doesn't match the inside.
What is the attitude of hypocrisy?
I want what I can get but I don't want
to give anything in response.
Here
and when he is entrusted he's
treacherous. As soon as you show your
soft underbelly to him or as soon as
they are able to learn something about
you that is sensitive, a secret,
anything they are entrusted with, they
use it as leverage. This is not
something of, oh, this is my Muslim's
back, let me protect it. No, no, you're
not dealing with that kind of person.
You're dealing with someone who is
looking for leverage and looking to
exploit at every turn. This is his
nature. a wild animal, if you turn
your back to a wild animal, what
happens? They pounce. They take
advantage.
He says,
"And when he pledges allegiance or makes
a truce or treaty, he will not follow
follow through with that and he will
prove treacherous."
And another one that could be one of the
most important traits that is often
overlooked.
Listen to the words
and when he disputes
he becomes sinful. Now this is from
What is
in the Arabic language?
Is that a person
propagate that a person
that a person initiate
sinfulness,
vulgarity and exaggeration in in haram?
This is fuul, right?
And as fujul was taken from the root
word when something
expands from nothing.
This is why we refer to the sunrise as
what?
Why? Because it cuts across the horizon
and the light comes from seemingly
nowhere.
This is the nature of the hypocrite. The
nature is when he disputes
all that venom starts to come out.
It's not it's not within the limitations
of dispute. We all dispute. We're
brothers, right? We're brothers. We all
dispute with each other. Who of us does
not have a dispute with another? The
companions had disputes. Who are the
most virtuous companions out of all the
companions?
Huh? Abu Bakr and after Abu Bakr Abu
Bakr and Omar had multiple arguments and
got upset with each other and when he
complained to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam about each other. These
happened this happens with every two
human beings. Why? Because whenever you
have two free wills, they must clash. It
will happen. This is one of the
evidences that our creator is one.
Because if there were two free wills
that could create
and so the point here is that disputes
happen. But how does the Muslim believer
dispute? And how does the lonely, lonely
hypocrite dispute?
The hypocrite cannot control himself.
When he disputes, he wants to hurt and
harm his whomever he is disputing with.
He could be friends for 20 years with
someone, but as soon as that dispute
happens, he will try to tear him down in
the most petty way possible, in any way
possible.
There's a difference between disputing
and
overstepping and attempting to harm and
attack the other person. The prophet
sallall.aiam
said,
insulting the Muslim is
it is rebellious sinfulness
and fighting the Muslim is an an act of
a type of the actions of the
is what disbelievers do. This is not
what Muslims do. And so
So, when he disputes, he goes as far as
he can to inflict as much harm as
possible,
whether it be with insults,
belittlement,
, venom, vitri all in the heart,
right? A desire to see their Muslim
brother pulled apart, right?
And this this here is not a dispute.
This now is hypocrisy. If I dispute with
my Muslim brother, no matter how much
they upset me or they're my brother, a
Muslim knows his boundaries, right? Even
if he was so upset, if you were to ask
him, "Would you to see harm come to
him?" Of course not. He's my brother,
but I'm upset with him. That's a
believer.
a hypocrite? No. In his heart of hearts,
he would wish all kinds of harm on this
person. He would love to see him picked
apart
because of the venom and vitrial that
has poisoned his heart. We're not like
snakes. Allah designed the snake to have
venom and not kill it. We as human
beings are the first ones to be poisoned
when we have venom in our heart.
You know a snake it has a place in its
body to keep the venom and it's healthy.
It doesn't affect it. Human being
doesn't have that place. When we have
venom in our heart the first person to
be poisoned is us. We're poisoned by
that.
fragile. He will backbite. He will lash
out. He or she and this happens often
and sad to say and we will end with
this. If you were to say where do you
most often see this in your experience,
I see it between a man and his wife.
Now,
why why is that? Because our environment
is a fake hypocritical environment.
Everything around you. All every element
of your life and my life right here in
America is fake.
Tell me what is what is real about it?
What is real? How many politicians have
smiled at us? Which smile is the real
smile? Tell us. Huh? The big smile. Even
the way people talk, even the way
Muslims now have learned to talk, they
come on the
What is this? This is something that
if he saw this behavior, he would have
the person whipped for this kind of
fakery.
This is fakery, right? No matter what's
happening, if I stab you in the back,
just make sure it's with a velvet glove.
As Makaveli says in his book, The
Prince, this is the hypocrisy of
this is not
the Muslims.
You will not be abused amongst them. You
will not get any fake smiles or fake
hugs with them. Right?
And this was the honor of Islam. When we
started to tend into fakery, exploit
each other's secrets, exploit each
other's vulnerabilities,
this is when our body, because the
Muslim is all connected as one body.
The more this cancer grew in our
collective body, the weaker and more
vulnerable to our enemies we have
become. Who is the first person we start
with when we start to make change on the
earth?
The first person we start with when we
start to make change, the person that
looks back at you from the mirror.
That's the first one. We don't learn
this knowledge here to go and beat other
people over the head with it. , the
said
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said and take it to his wife and beat
her over the head with it.
It's not for that. I begin with the guy
that's looking back at me in the mirror.
Allah says, "Protect yourselves and your
family." We begin with ourselves and
then we spread it organically. If you do
it and you do it and you do it and I do
it and we all gather in one place, that
cancer starts to be flushed out and
purged and we start to become healthy
again. It's not easy. It's not easy to
tell the truth all the time. It's not
easy to always be trustworthy. It's not
easy to restrain yourself when you're
angry.
But this is what the discipline of Islam
is all about. It is for lions. It's not
for mere men.
Subhanahu waala.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.